[MUSIC PLAYING]
MO FONG: Good
morning, everybody.
How is everyone doing?
All right.
We're so excited for
all of you to be here.
And thank you, Shenaz, for
sharing your wonderful story
with us today.
It's really relevant to the
announcement we have for you.
So as you have
heard and you know,
we are fully committed to
supporting women in tech,
women who want to be in
tech, and young women who
are just starting to
dream about being in tech.
So Women Techmakers and
Engineering Education
at Google, which we
affectionately call Eng Edu--
we have combined forces,
because we're both passionate
about providing resources and
computer science education
to build community
and to increase
the visibility of role models.
And that's all of you
in this room today.
And hopefully, we can
inspire more young women
to participate in the field.
So before we actually
know what we can do,
we had to do a little
bit of research
to understand why women
and underrepresented groups
are so fewly represented
in computer science.
So we partnered with Gallup
on a multi-year study
to understand the root causes.
And today, we are unveiling
a new research brief focused
on girls to understand
precisely what the issues are
and what we can do.
So here are some of the
key research findings.
What we found is that girls are
1.7 times less likely than boys
to be encouraged by
parents and teachers
to go into computer science.
And they are twice as less
likely to see themselves
on screen and in media.
So it's no wonder
that girls are half as
confident as boys when it
comes to engaging in computer
science.
But there's a lot we can do.
And in the research brief, we
highlight some recommendations
that all of you can help
us participate and do
to help encourage girls most
about social and cultural
encouragement.
One of the most important
things we can do
is to change the narrative.
So we want to see
more diverse images.
And we want to tell stories
of computer scientists
that are relevant and
that they can relate to.
And so by doing
so, hopefully they
will be inspired
to change the world
and maybe even pursue
careers that involve CS.
So to get us
started, we're going
to be releasing a new resource
tool to do exactly that
and to share our stories.
So we're announcing three new
careers with code Expeditions
today.
And for those of you who are
not familiar with Google career
Expeditions and the app and
also with career Expeditions,
it's basically
virtual field trips.
So as you can imagine, a lot
of field trips are costly,
or they're logistically
difficult to get to, especially
if you're talking about the
International Space Station
or Antarctica or Machu Picchu.
And you can actually download
those on Expeditions as well.
But most Expeditions
don't focus on careers.
So what we've done
with this tool
is to give it a
little bit of a twist.
So with career Expeditions,
we've gone out,
interviewed
professionals, asked them
what do they like
about their jobs,
we shadowed them in
their environments,
and we learned about how they
got to where they are today
and how they're incorporating
technology into their field.
So it's kind of like a virtual
career tour, if you will.
And the beauty of
this is that you
can meet these professionals
wherever they are,
and you can watch
them wherever you are.
So let's get started, because
we have three inaugural careers
with code Expeditions featuring
Angelica, Victoria, and Sue.
And they are stellar,
amazing women
who have used technologies
in so many interesting ways
in their fields.
You can follow their
stories by downloading
the Google Expedition's
app into your phone.
And then you can use
a cardboard device
in order to share their
stories with students using
the Explorer or the Guide mode.
So what can you do today?
You can read about the
research that's in your bags,
or you can follow the
link on the screen.
Second, you can try
Google Expeditions, again
downloading the application.
And in your bag, you
have these cardboards,
so you can check it out today.
And you can sync your phone
with it and play around with it.
Or you can actually experience
it using a live demo
that we're going to be hosting
at the reception today.
And the wonderful thing
about Expeditions,
too, is that this
is not the end,
because next week for
Women's History Month
and also International
Women's Day,
we're going to be announcing
even more career Expeditions
for you to take a look at.
And lastly, as Shenaz has also
encouraged all of us to do,
share your story.
And you can share it
with someone today.
Share it with a young
person in your life.
And you have an opportunity
to nominate yourself
and your story to be shared
with a nationwide network
of students at
CareersWithCode.com/Share.
So thank you so much
for being here today.
I hope you really enjoy today.
And I'll turn it back to Shenaz.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]